[Applaudissements]
allez alors là on a ce qu'on attend
nation l'attendait été pprt
et oui parce qu'alors on a appris
qu'elle 6 bosser sur une version de tpm
paix vaart est aussi ils ont carrément
pris fin il ya m6 tout mon team et tout
le monde sait où ces personnes mais
n'ont jamais l'alsace et la lorraine
c'est alors qu'ils ont faim pilotes
cyril je passe vous saviez non on avait
ruiné mes chiots petit test c'était pnp
voyez version arte avec de la culture
étoiles intérieur à bages en effet assez
ressemblants regardez ce que ça te
regarde on regarde tous et bienvenue
touche pas mais j'ai dit ah merci les
chéris vous étiez 42 à nos garde des
garçons on a battu notre record tout de
suite se sent belle émission à notre
invité joseph salvat directeur de
l'opéra trop fort j'adore à vous le
savez c'est mon bébé va y avoir de la
cadart je le sens en cas d'arcadia
canada on va s'éclater autour de la
table jeux wii d'hortensias kate avec le
directeur du cnrs chaire lui le mois de
ça va mon bébé directeur du cabinet du
ministre la culture marie annick du
ventre eu de télérama et mon chouchou
mon loulou joachim lou doillon
bibliothécaire bien sûr chez les adore
taz un sms de mahler alors mes bottés on
va un petit peu ce béton
marie-annick vous avez un coup de coeur
alors là c'est chez vous la cette vidéo
j'ai eu la chance de l'avoir avec
l'artiste que nous connaissons tous et
que nous chérissons vladimir poutine
j'ai beaucoup à eux deux et qui de plus
drôle que lui pour nous délivrer cette
vidéo que nous allons nous délecter
regardez regardez je vous jure ça c'est
magnifique sans déconner c'est
magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui par mois là plus personne en régie
perso vous allez c'est pas grave c'est
la cabine abl
on aimait chez eux et je sais que vous
l'adorez c'était pour avaya nordine qui
me le dit dans l'oreillette c'est ça
vous devinez qui est derrière le rideau
alors d'après vous est-ce que c'est un
chevreuil qui se prend à un doigt dans
le cul par philippe candeloro sergei pop
à l'offre lieu dans ces révoltes
tchécoslovaquie et à l'as cannes à
l'uqar est demain je le sais mais bébé à
la maison vous allez être comme des
dingues chaussée puisque c'est mon bébé
ça tu nous fait une petite démo du
spectacle c'est parti je ne sais pas
c'était complet on ressemble maintenant
toute la souffrance de son peuple tout
en gardant la grâce d'un signal et
usages d'agde h talent souffrant d'un
signe c'est parti vous réagissez
bookmakers les amis merci d'avoir été
avec nous sur arte merci retrouve demain
n'oubliez pas la télé c'est que de la
merde
[Musique]